freunde der sonne hört euch das an ist
homosexualität vga sowie schwul oder
lesbisch sind deine gene für knappe fünf
euro will die diese app das verraten
laut anbietern basiert auf den
ergebnissen einer großen studie zur
genetik von homosexualität die im august
im renommierten journal science
veröffentlicht wurde ist das denn
überhaupt möglich kann man anhand der
gene die sexuelle neigung eines menschen
ablesen ja heute frage das ist unser
funk kollege costas vom kanal kostet das
kind gleich selbst schwul bin
beschäftigt mich solche fragen natürlich
auch er wir so also auf der einen seite
betrug sexuellen ja oft vorgeworfen dass
das nur ein lifestyle wäre den sie sich
ausgesucht haben oder eine entscheidung
die sie getroffen haben und in so einer
situation war es natürlich cool wenn man
sagen könnte
haye ist es nicht so die wissenschaft
hat gezeigt dass man damit geboren wird
und dass man sich das nicht aussuchen
auf der anderen seite kann das doch
super gefährlich sein weil so ein wissen
auf jeden fall auch missbraucht werden
kann
das ist jetzt nur ein gedanke aber
stellt euch mal vor man könnte vor der
geburt feststellen ob ein kind eventuell
homosexuell wird oder nicht vielleicht
würde dann im ländern in denen
homosexualität noch illegal ist so ein
kind abgetrieben werden die kurze
antwort auf die frage steckt unsere
sexualität in unseren genen ist ja und
nein für die lange antwort wohl durch
ein tee macht es euch gemütlich wir
steigen jetzt ein in die faszinierende
wissenschaft hinter der erblichkeit von
homosexualität homosexuelles verhalten
also sex mit einem
gleichgeschlechtlichen partner findet
man je nach studie in zwei bis zehn
prozent der bevölkerung und ist
wahrscheinlich schon so alt wie die
menschheit selbst dokumentiert ist
homosexuelles verhalten in
verschiedensten kulturen und seit
tausenden von jahren auch im tierreich
ist sex mit einem gleichgeschlechtlichen
partner alles andere als sowohl in
haltung als auch in freier wildbahn sex
mit einem gleichgeschlechtlichen partner
ist also schon mal keine spezifisch
menschliche erfindung oder laune aber
ist homosexualität genetisch bei vielen
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen kommt die alte
nature versus deutscher debatte auf ist
homosexualität erblich oder ist sie
umweltbedingter persönlichkeitsmerkmale
sind eigentlich immer beides also
gleichzeitig genetische und
umweltbedingte das wissen wir unter
anderem dank zwillingsstudien mehr dazu
findet ihr in diesem video wo ich die
erblichkeit von intelligenz ausführlich
erklären warum zwillinge weil wir bei
zwillingen den genetischen
verwandtschaftsgrad kennen also zum
beispiel eineiige zwillinge haben zu 100
prozent die gleiche dna
das bedeutet wenn sich diese eineiigen
zwillinge in irgendwelchen
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen unterscheiden
dann müssen diese unterschiede umwelt
bedingt sein das heißt aber nicht dass
diese eigenschaft an sich komplett
umweltbedingte nehmen doch mal das
beispiel intelligenz also eineiige
zwillinge können unterschiedliche iq sei
dieser unterschied der es um welt
bedient aber intelligenz an sich kann
natürlich auch genetisch sein und wie
groß dieser genetische anteil ist das
können wir nur herausfinden wenn wir die
zwillinge mit menschen vergleichen die
eben nicht die gleiche dna also
vergleicht man eine gruppe ein eiliger
zwillinge mit einer gruppe zweieiige
zwillinge zweieiige zwillinge haben
nämlich im mittel zu 50 prozent die
gleiche dna im fall intelligenz
beobachten jetzt folgendes eineiige
zwillinge haben einen ehrlicheren iq als
zweieiige zwillinge und das obwohl sich
die umwelteinflüsse zwischen zwillingen
nicht groß unterscheiden dürfen daraus
können wir jetzt schließen
intelligenz ist teilweise erblich und
war jetzt bei zwillingen den genetischen
verwandtschaftsgrad genau kennt 100%
gleiche dna was 50% gleiche dna kann man
damit jetzt genau ausrechnen wie groß
dieser genetische anteil genau ist auch
hier kann ich ein video auf dass
intelligenz video verweisen
dadurch dass bei gelegenheit gerne mal
komplett an hier rechne ich es nämlich
genau vor so bei homosexualität ergeben
solche zwillingsstudien also je nach
studie und datensatz folgendes die
unterschiede in sexuelle neigung oder in
sexuellen
sind zu 20 bis 50 prozent genetisch
bedingt das bedeutet ja homosexualität
ist wenn auch nur teilweise genetisch
bedingt also ist die nächste frage
welche konkreten gene sind denn genau
dafür verantwortlich kann man anhand der
gene so etwas wie einen homosexualität
faktor ablesen oder platt gesagt kann
man war ja sagen vg ja jetzt wird's band
fangen wir an mit den basics unser genom
der große plan
unsere gesamte genetische information
der ganze funktions und bauplan unseres
körpers ist in unserem genom
niedergeschrieben das genom besteht
konkret aus 46 chromosomen bzw aus 23
chromosomenpaare wir bekommen ein
chromosom set von unserer mutter einst
von unserem vater vererbt
beziehungsweise dass sie es jetzt ein
typisch männlicher chromosomensatz wo
das 23h aus zwei unterschiedlichen
chromosomen besteht xy kennen wir bei
einem typisch weiblichen chromosomensatz
wäre hier ein paar aus zwei
x-chromosomen jedes chromosom besteht
wiederum aus einem dna molekülen ein dna
molekül kann man sich vorstellen wie
einen sehr langen fahrten bilder von dna
kennt ihr ja das sieht ihr normalerweise
nicht so aus wie diese chromosomen in
diesen fotos müsst ihr euch vorstellen
dass die dna verden
ja ich sag mal so stark auf gekoppelt
sind
so wie jetzt dieser faden hierbei das
und dadurch kommen die dna fäden zu
ihrer stäbchen vor jedes dna molekül ist
wiederum aus vier verschiedenen
bausteinen aufgebaut aus vier
verschiedenen nukleotiden die nukleotide
unterscheiden sich darin wie diese base
hier aussieht es gibt hier nämlich vier
verschiedene phasen und zwar adenin
thymin guanin und cytosin also a b oder
c
mit diesen vier buchstaben ist unser
genom also geschrieben also je nachdem
in welcher reihenfolge diese vier
buchstaben sich zur dna zusammensetzen
ergibt sich so unser individueller
bauplanen unsere chromosomen oder unsere
dna sind aber nicht das
wie unsere gene die gene sind teil
unserer chromosomen die gene sind die
abschnitte der dna die die bauanleitung
für ein bestimmtes einzelteil enthalten
zb für ein enzym oder für einen rezeptor
in jetzt eine eigenschaft genetisch
erblich ist dann heißt dass eines oder
mehrere gene sind von mensch zu mensch
unterschiedlich
und das führt dann zu kleinen oder
großen unterschieden darin wie ein enzym
eine zelle oder im körper funktioniert
und das führt dann zu kleinen oder
großen unterschieden zwischen menschen
wenn ich also eingehen finden möchte das
für eine bestimmte eigenschaft
verantwortlich ist dann kann ich schauen
welche stellen im genom bei menschen mit
dieser eigenschaft anders aussehen als
bei menschen ohne diese eigenschaft dazu
muss ich nur das genom möglichst vieler
menschen entschlüsseln genotypisierung
zeig mir deine dna und ich sag dir wer
du bist
es ist inzwischen technisch möglich das
gesamte menschliche genom buchstabe für
buchstabe abzulesen
man sagt dazu auch das genom
sequenzieren nun ist es aber in der
praxis ziemlich teuer solche
vollständige genom sequenzierung und zu
machen zumindest zu teuer um das jetzt
für große studien massenweise
durchzuführen einfacher und günstiger
kann man das ganze gestalten wenn man
nicht das gesamte genom sondern nur
einzelne buchstaben betrachtet jetzt
endlich ist der großteil unseres genoms
zwischen verschiedenen menschen
identisch da wir alle menschen sind aber
in unserer dna gibt es viele stellen an
denen ein einzelner buchstabe
ausgetauscht sein kann also ein mensch
hat ein anderer mensch hat an diese
einzelnen stellen im genom die jetzt
eben von mensch zu mensch
unterschiedlich sein können nennt man es
nicht so spricht man hier snp aus die
abkürzung für single nucleotide
polymorphisms also übersetzt die
vielgestaltigkeit eines einzelnen notiz
dieses netz stellen sind deswegen so
interessant weil sie
mehr als 90 der genetischen unterschiede
zwischen menschen aus machen anstatt
jetzt also das gesamte genom buchstabe
für buchstabe abzulesen kann man jetzt
auch einfach dieses netz betrachten und
schauen welche einzelnen buchstaben an
diesen stellen sitzen das nennt sich
dann nicht mehr sequenzieren sondern
geno typisieren und das wird in modernen
studien für mehrere hunderttausend slips
gleichzeitig gemacht und damit kommen
wir zu der erwähnten studie über die
genetik von homosexualität zwei
verschiedene datenbanken lieferten den
forschern daten von rund 500.000
teilnehmern zu diesen daten gehörten
genotypisierung sowie antworten auf
verschiedene befragungen
damit wollte man jetzt herausfinden
welche clips unseres genoms stehen in
verbindung mit homosexualität sogar
jetzt ist die frage wer ist bin
homosexuell oder oder ab wann ist man
dann homosexuell beschreibt dass die
sexuelle orientierung oder das sexuelle
verhalten ist damit jemand gemeint der
ausschließlich sex mit dem gleichen
geschlecht hat fehlt auch schon jemand
dazu der ab und zu mal sex mit dem
gleichen geschlecht hat oder vielleicht
auch leute die das niemals ausleben aber
die sich trotzdem zum gleichen
geschlecht hingezogen fühlen ist die
frage ob man das überhaupt auf basis der
praktischen sexuellen auslegung
definieren kann die forscher entschieden
sich dafür sexualverhalten zu
untersuchen
nicht unbedingt weil das der beste
indikator dafür ist auch jemand
homosexuell ist oder nicht denn wie
kostas auch sagt nicht jeder hat die
freiheit oder die mut seine sexuelle
neigung auch auszuleben aber für das
sexualverhalten hatten die forscher den
größten datensatz alle teilnehmer hatten
nämlich angegeben ob sie schon mal sex
mit einem gleichgeschlechtlichen partner
hatten anhand der antworten zeigten die
forscher die teilnehmer in zwei gruppen
erstens noch nie sex mit dem gleichen
geschlecht gehabt zweitens schon mal sex
mit dem gleichen geschlecht gehabt
wichtige info schon mal um diese studie
zu verstehen es wurde hier nicht
homosexualität untersucht denn
homosexualität lässt sich ja nicht
darüber definieren dass jemand schon mal
sex mit jemandem vom gleichen geschlecht
hatte
das ist den forschern übrigens auch klar
und dazu gruppe 2 auch alle menschen
rein ziel die einmal sex mit dem kleinen
geschichten müssen wir davon ausgehen
dass man hier nicht nur genetische
besonderheiten findet die mit
homosexualität zu tun haben sondern
vielleicht auch mit offenheit abenteuer
lustigkeit risikofreudigkeit das sind
alles persönlichkeitsmerkmale die
ebenfalls teilweise genetisch sind
trotzdem wollten die forscher wissen
gibt es denn genetische unterschiede
zwischen diesen beiden gruppen und ja
die gab es die ergebnisse der studie die
forscher konnten einzelne clips
identifizieren die statistisch
signifikant mit homosexuellen verhalten
verknüpft war
wer zum beispiel auf chromosom nummer
sieben einen bestimmten stelle der dna
ein g statt einer hatte hatte mit einer
höheren wahrscheinlichkeit schon mal sex
mit einem gleichgeschlechtlichen partner
von solchen statistisch signifikanten
snitch fanden die forscher fünf stück
aber statistisch signifikant heißt nicht
automatisch groß das könnt ihr euch
schon mal generell merken hier das beste
beispiel dafür der einfluss dieser fünf
slips also dieser fünf dna stellen war
zwar groß im vergleich zu anderen snip
aber der gesamt einfluss auf das
sexuelle verhalten war winzig es ist wie
sagen wir alle meiler abonnenten machen
jetzt gemeinsam eine sammelstelle für
den guten zweck und jeder spendet im
schnitt 1 euro das heißt willkommen bei
einer gesamtsumme von über 500.000 euro
raus jetzt spenden wir als team also
sagen wir melanie lassen ich späten
jetzt am meisten zum beispiel 20 euro
dann haben wir mit diesem 20 euro
natürlich viel mehr gespendet als der 1
euro durchschnitt aber bei einer
gesamtsumme von über 500.000 euro können
wir uns in unseren
man sich eure keinen riesigen einfluss
auf die kappe schreiben versteht ihr
wählt nicht gesprochen konnten die
forscher mit diesen fünf nix also 520
euro beiträge identifizieren aber selbst
mit 5 x 20 euro erklärt sich noch keine
500.000 euro spende
es gibt sehr viele slips also sehr viele
einzustellen in der dna die sich in
ihrem einfluss alle summieren
die aber jeweils einen nur sehr kleinen
einfluss auf das sexuelle verhalten
haben
nummer eins so etwas wie ein homogen
gibt es nicht komisch sexuelles
verhalten ist poly gehen poly gehen
bedeutet es hängt von verschiedenen
genen gleichzeitig ab und in diesem fall
sind es sehr viele verschiedene gene
jeweils nur einen sehr kleinen einfluss
aber komplexität hin oder her und so
regine haben ja einen einfluss das heißt
kann man jetzt anhand der gene sexuelles
verhalten voraus sagen die forscher
haben es versucht man kann nämlich für
jeden snip also für jede
charakteristische dna stelle berechnen
wie dieses nimmt die wahrscheinlichkeit
verändert dass diese person schon einmal
sex mit einem gleichgeschlechtlichen
partner hat also man geht dann die slips
einzeln durch ist es nicht nur 1 hier
finden wir zum beispiel buchstabe a
dadurch wird die wahrscheinlichkeit
erhöht tipp nummer zwei hier finden wir
buchstaben dadurch wird die
wahrscheinlichkeit erniedrigt und so
weiter
das macht man dann für ganz viele snacks
wie gesagt für mehrere hunderttausend
und am ende bekommt man so eine art
gesamtpunktzahl für die
wahrscheinlichkeit den sogenannten
politik score und leute es lohnt sich so
ein bisschen was über pager diskurs zu
wissen denn es gibt immer mehr anbieter
und unternehmen die mit genau diesen
politics kurs irgendwelche services
anbieten die nicht selten fragwürdig
sind zb angeblich perfekt
personalisierte ernährungspläne auf
basis seiner gene ob jetzt so was
quatsch oder lädiertes das könnt ihr
natürlich nur ein wenn die
wissenschaftlichen basics kennt also die
grundidee der sohn lvg you wäre ich
reiche die nase
eine speichelprobe daraus werden die
slips bestimmt mit denen wir diese
politik score erstellt und je höher das
korps desto wahrscheinlicher ist für
mich sechs mit einer frau
das problem bei solchen politik scores
ist dass sie sehr ungenau sein können
vor allem wenn wir sehr vieles nix haben
deren einzelne einfluss auf die zu
untersuchende eigenschaft so winzig ist
wird in unserem fall homosexuelles
verhalten beim scoring kommt bei jedem
einzelnen snip ein gewisser fehler hinzu
und je mehr es nebst wir unsere
betrachtung mit einbeziehen desto mehr
fehler summieren sich dann auch immens
co mann kann aber auch nicht pauschal
sagen dass politik scores generell ist
sind oder das ist generell nur eine vage
raterei ist das kommt wirklich auf die
zu untersuchende eigenschaft an und auf
die größe des datenpools also es gibt
bereiche in denen politik scores eine
ganz gute vorauswahl getroffen haben zum
beispiel bei der zucht von nutztieren
bei homosexuellen verhalten er gab der
praxistest nun folgendes menschen mit
höherem politik score kam tatsächlich
mit einer höheren wahrscheinlichkeit an
dass sie schon einmal sex mit einem
gleichgeschlechtlichen partner hatten
aber trotz statistischer signifikanz war
diese assoziation sehr klein
die politik scores erklärt nämlich in
diesem praxistest gerade mal ein prozent
der unterschiede heißt wir können zwar
sicher sagen dass homosexuelles
verhalten von vielen verschiedenen genen
abhängt aber trotz nummer zwei hier sind
derzeit technisch nicht dazu in der lage
sexuelles verhalten mittels gentest
vorauszusagen und jeder der etwas
anderes behauptet behauptet einfach
quatsch wie zum beispiel die app die app
wurde inzwischen übrigens runter
genommen denn die hersteller bekamen
einen riesen backlash allen voran von
den autoren der studie die die falsche
darstellung der forschungsergebnisse
scharf kritisiert übrigens auch den
perfekten ernährungsplan kammer mit
politik scores nicht erstellen also
spart euch da
doch welche konsequenzen zieht man jetzt
aus dem ergebnis dieser studie
wenn ich ehrlich bin ist das das beste
ergebnis das ich mir vorstellen können
denn auf der einen seite beweist der
genetische anteil eben dass
homosexualität nicht eine willkürliche
entscheidung ist die man sich aussuchen
kann
trotzdem ist ja so klein dass er ja
eigentlich missbraucht und durch die
homosexuelle verwendet werden kann und
noch etwas ist ganz wichtig genetisch
ist nicht dasselbe wie biologisch anders
gesagt umwelt bedingt ist viel mehr als
nur erzieher oder erfahrung es gibt auch
biologische umwelteinflüsse wie zum
beispiel der hormonstatus im mutterleib
zum beispiel steigt bei jungs die
wahrscheinlichkeit schwul zu sein
mit der anzahl ihrer älteren brüder eine
mögliche erklärung dafür ist der
einfluss über das immunsystem der mutter
während der schwangerschaft der mit
jeder jungs schwangerschaft größer wird
also das wäre jetzt so ein biologischer
umwelteinfluss der junge selbst hat
keinen einfluss drauf liegt aber auch
nicht in den genen das heißt born this
way also ich kann nichts dafür wie ich
geboren werde bezieht sowohl gegner als
auch umwelt mit allen die vorstellung
dass homosexualität eine lifestyle
choice sei ist also definitiv falsch wir
wissen es gibt definitiv einen
genetischen einfluss und dass es weitere
biologische umwelteinflüsse gibt ist
nicht auszuschließen wenn man selber
homosexuell ist dann wird man ja immer
wieder mit so blöden kommentaren
konfrontiert deutete eben sagen 'das hat
gegen die natur oder so und das ist ein
handfester beweis dass es eben nicht so
ist und ich kann mir vorstellen dass das
leuten die selbst kater weise und ihre
sexualität zu entdecken
auch so ein bisschen sicherheit und
angst nehmen kann weil das eben zeigt
sie haben darauf keinen einfluss
sie müssen sich deswegen nicht verrückt
machen trotzdem sind die ethischen
bedenken bei dieser forschung noch nicht
vom tisch ist forschung immer gut ich
hoffe ihr erkennt dass ich hier mit
meinen hintergründen
regenbogen darstellen wollte ich weiß
ich habe nicht alle farbe und vor allem
sind sie nicht in der richtigen
reihenfolge
es tut mir leid es gibt heute schon
unternehmen die bei einer künstlichen
befruchtung deinen besten embryo für
dich raussuchen wollen dafür werden auch
politik scores benutzt hier wollen zum
beispiel embryos mit erhöhtem
genetischen risiko für bluthochdruck
aussortieren oder welche deren politics
kurs darauf hinweisen dass sie besonders
klein wären ja selbst die auswahl des
besten kuss wollen sie in zukunft
verfolgen noch ist die antwort ja zum
glück das bringt alles nichts also diese
designerbaby idee ist technisch gar
nicht umsetzbar weil die politik scores
viel zu ungenau sind übrigens selbst bei
eigenschaften wie der körpergröße die
eine sehr starke genetische komponente
hat aber die forschung entwickelt sich
hier rasant weit umso wichtiger für mich
ist dass wir uns jetzt schon darüber
gedanken machen wie wir damit gerne
umgehen möchten denn es gibt ja auch
schon heute technische möglichkeiten die
diskussionswürdig sind also jede
schwangere kann heute in der
pränataldiagnostik feststellen lassen ob
das baby down syndrom haben wird oder
nicht und gegebenenfalls abtreiben
was ist also wir haben diesen test nicht
gemacht weil wir das baby so oder so
behalten hätten stelle sich vor man kann
in der pränataldiagnostik irgendwann
alles möglich fest zum beispiel ob das
kind ein risiko für homosexualität hat
also
das wäre es für mich oder für uns als
eltern total irrelevant aber das sehen
ja leider nicht alles was denkt ihr
gibt es forschung von der man lieber die
finger lassen sollte oder ist mehr
wissen immer besser und falls ihr selbst
wir seit und durch dieses video
vielleicht zum ersten mal auch mal
abgestoßen seid herzlich willkommen
bleibt gerne hier wenn ihr euch für
wissenschaft interessiert ansonsten
schaut doch gerne mal bei costas vorbei
ja ich bin costa
ich habe auch ein kanal bei funk zurzeit
beschäftige ich mich viel mit lg chem
auf einem kanal
abgesehen davon zeichnen ich sehr gerne
ich interessiere mich für animationen
bewegen und auch zu dem themen werdet
ihr immer wieder was auf meinen kanal
finden
das heißt wenn euch das interessiert
würde ich mich auf jeden fall freuen
wenn du mal vorbeischaut dann hoffe ich
natürlich dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat vergesst mich einen daumen
hoch zu geben und auch diesen kanal zu
abonnieren
mai und ihr team machen einfach die
besten videos an welcher stelle nochmal
danke dass ich dabei sein durfte dann
auch ich bin schon wirklich lange fern
von diesem kanal und ja ich fand es echt
cool dass wir jetzt mal zusammenarbeiten
konnten dann hoffe ich dass euch gut
geht und wir sind zum nächsten mal ein